so I've seen the first six episodes of
Picard season three and I'm just gonna
say they're fantastic
um I think fans are going to be very
very happy what are you allowed to say
about season three that everybody should
come and watch it uh
um
what what can I say I I think this is
the perfect send-off for uh the the Next
Generation cast for me personally I can
say that I go on a a huge Voyage as a
character no no pun intended a guy that
is
desperately trying to work out who he is
you know he thinks he's got quite a
thick skin and he's quite head sure and
smart and uh and and and and I suppose
Fearless but there's something that's
driving that fear and we don't know what
that is yet we don't know what is is is
is is eating away him but something
isn't quite right with his character so
he is discovering who he is both in
terms of his relationships to others but
also
the bigger picture you really do have an
arc in the first six episodes and get to
do a lot of different things yeah how
much did Terry tell you when you got
cast what this was all going to be and
how much was it you finding out script
by script so Terry who's become such a
dear friend he he made it very clear to
me early on what was in store for this
character and I was white
because suppose I was gobsmacked because
to be given an opportunity to join such
a wonderful franchise franchise
franchise like this and be a part of
that or in a role that had had all these
so multifaceted and had so much uh scope
uh was a real a real honor I think I'm
going to struggle being able to do any
other role on the back of this one
because it it i as you said I got to do
everything like I I really was given
free reign to do everything and he's
he's involved in every episode and quite
quite significantly and I I relished I
really really loved every minute of it
the season is 10 episodes uh do you have
a favorite episode of the 10 and why no
I mean I'm I do think the finale's
really special for for many of our cast
members and also I I think what I love
about the season as it goes along is I
keep watching episodes actually and
going well that's a good one oh no
that's a good one because but it just
builds in crescendos and and I feel that
Terry's achieved what he set out to do
he wanted to create a cinematic moment
but he wanted these 10 episodes to feel
like one long movie and I think that's
what it is so rather than picking one
episode I think there's so many great
stories in there and and the characters
are so well thought out even like the
new bridge crew I think they're so on
point with everything they do you know
the score is on point uh the way it it
looks the way it's shot and that's then
that's completely juxtaposed to what's
going on
uh with with the sort of the the
relationships and the family drama and
and then the big scale of of of what
might be around the corner so I can't
pick one episode I think it's it just
builds as a whole piece one of the
things I think about season three is and
I've seen all the first two seasons I do
think you could watch season three
without having seen the first two
seasons uh do you feel that way I
actually I I do uh I do I feel that
of course it would be great to have an
understanding of who who the other
characters are if you're not familiar
already
um but I think that's what's quite
intriguing about season three is
it it toes the line between a
stand-alone moment so you don't have to
necessarily have watched anything you
know related to this before but it is
still also tying things up in a
wonderful way for so many well-known
characters when you think back on the
filming of season three is there a day
or two that you will always remember
whether it be because you messed up on
set really bad or you got something in
one take you know just one of those days
I mean I let the props department down
quite a lot because I've kept breaking
the phaser okay
I think I missed the holster a couple of
times and it the nib of the phaser broke
off but I mean uh I mean that was kind
of memorable for the amount of grief I
took for that
um but also
I you know there's some I had some some
pretty lovely scenes both with Gates and
and
with Patrick certainly later on in the
season as well I mean I was I was very
lucky because I feel that I had
I was given the opportunity to bounce
around
um many storylines and and work quite
closely with with many of the cast I I
really enjoyed the stuff I got to do
with seven of nine as well with Jerry I
thought we had some really nice little
moments as well I'm just gonna say
congrats and I can't wait to see where
it's all going thank you thank you for
your time cool thank you